Now it's time to modify our application.
And before I do this, I'm going to suggest, that you
initialize a Git repository, so you can always revert any mistakes you make.
I always do this.
In my case, when I got the code base from GitHub, I made that repository.
And sure enough.
I'll use PWD to see that I'm on the desktop inside of my to do folder, and
I can say, get status, and sure enough, there is a give repository.
Get log, shows me that it turns out I've actually made some commits.
Now if you do this, you'll see my commits as well.
You won't see any commits by yourself, because you haven't made any yet.
But as you make changes, if you like the changes you make.
Go ahead and use get to make commits and keep track of whats going on.
I'll type queue here.
Now if you really want to you can skip the git steps steps but
I highly recommend learning it at some point.
If you don't already know it Udacity is a version and
there are tons of other good resources around the web as well.
Using version control means, its easy to experiment and
that's the exciting thing.
We're not going to mess up our application accidentally.
Since gits, our version control system, is keeping track of what we change and
when, we can play with code without fear.
If we mess up, we just ask git to revert our changes and we try again.
Now, I've already initialized my repo, but if you have to initialize a repo.
Git init is the command that you'll use.
I just wanted to point that out,
because this is my favorite command because it rhymes.
Get init.
Now, enough about get.
Our first feature modification will be a simple one.
We need to make it so that way, to do items that are marked as completed.
Show dash dash, done at the end.
Now, there are lots of ways you can make this happen, but
some art much cleaner and simpler than others.
Here's a good way of going about it.
Before you start, ask yourself a couple questions.
Should this change the way data is stored, or is it only a cosmetic change?
I like to consider that profound or cosmetic changes.
Is this a big change, or is it just the way it's visualized or shown?
Another question to ask yourself is, where could this change be implemented?
The view file?
The template?
Where?
And lastly, but most importantly in my mind.
Is there something already like this?
Does something already happen visually, when an item is marked complete?
If so, like for example the check mark, where is that implemented?
Maybe you should implement your change,
in the same place that this change happens.
Be a detective.
When you're done, we'll continue.